la juventud de hoy amb el lujo es
maleducada contradice a sus padres
mismos en la sociedad los jóvenes ya no
se ponen de pie cuando los mayores
entran al cuarto contradicen a sus
padres fanfarronean en la sociedad
devoran la mesa de los postres cruzan
las piernas y tiranizan a sus maestros
saben quién dijo esto
sócrates un filósofo del siglo quinto
antes de cristo- un hombre hace más o
menos dos mil quinientos años
dijo lo mismo que mi abuelita la semana
pasada bueno tal vez con un amistad por
dios o en mi tiempo no era así pero
prácticamente lo mismo hace poco tuve
que vivir una situación de supervivencia
extrema sumamente difícil y estresante
así es una reunión familiar mientras
combatía contra el constante
aburrimiento y las quejas de todos sobre
todo me puse a pensar por qué será que
me repite en esto y decidí analizar sus
temas sus críticas
viven conectados así es vivimos rodeados
de tecnología hoy en día llevamos con
nosotros un celular todos lados yo sin
mi celular entró en pánico no sé qué día
es me demoro mis buenos diez minutos
tratando de ver la hora en el reloj y me
toca contar con los deditos pero estoy
segura que mi abuelita antes le decía a
mi papá desenchufa tds walkman o ya dejé
el celular vas hablando como por dos
horas y antes me bisabuelita mi abuelita
algo como ya deja de estar pegado a la
radio uy ya deja de estar pegada a la
radio y antes de eso debió ser algo así
como soltar ese megáfono y ponerte a
estudiar
son unos adelantados la ciudad hay
abuelita creo que a mi edad ya tenías
como ocho hijos y papá cuántas veces me
has contado cómo te escapa vas a las
fiestas y que tu primera borrachera fue
a los 13
en mis tiempos a las fiestas se iba a
bailar y nuestra música que todo es un
chiste decide mételo sacarlo y
aplastarlo y no sé qué
ok lo admito la aleta es prácticamente
porno con ritmo pero a ver en sus
tiempos también había letras que tenían
su patanería o simplemente carecían de
sentido además yo prefiero mil veces
pelear hasta el piso que quedarme
sentada porque qué vergüenza porque no
me sacaron a bailar
estan altaneros y desobedientes yo he
escuchado mucho sobre esto y yo entiendo
y he visto personas que en verdad no
respetan para nada a sus papás y nunca
les van a obedecer en mi caso eso nunca
pasaría porque le tengo demasiado miedo
a mi mamá pero a ver mi mama se enoja
porque es algo porque no salgo porque
como mucho porque como poco porque
duermo mucho porque duermo poco
parece que nunca va a ser suficiente
para ellos yo creo que es bueno educar a
tus hijos pero tampoco creo que es bueno
como educaban antes los profesores
golpeaban a los alumnos los jóvenes no
podían ni siquiera hablar en el comedor
porque ellos nunca podrían tener la
razón y su opinión no importaba yo creo
que debe haber un balance entre eso
vocabulario palabras como el full o como
que son las malas palabras son la mayor
parte de nuestro vocabulario yo también
me siento tonta diciendo cosas como
fiestas hoy tiene esa foto o como que
haga ya entiendo tu punto pero también
sé que cuando tenía siete años mi mayor
insulto era sacarte la lengua y decirte
que no te voy a invitar a mi fiesta de
cumpleaños y que ahorita yo puede
escuchar a un niño de siete años decidir
muchas más malas palabras que son más
fuertes que idiota pero esa es nuestra
culpa como esperamos que los chiquitos
hablen mejor de lo que nosotros hablamos
en el día a día es tan cotidiano que no
nos damos cuenta pero es hipócrita decir
estos niños hablan horrible cuando
nosotros les damos el ejemplo
podría seguir así por horas pero les
preguntaré qué es lo que hace que una
generación sea mejor que otra
entorno
la experiencia la verdad es que nada no
somos diferentes a los de hace 10
o incluso 10.000 años simplemente
pasamos por el mismo proceso de
desarrollo dependiendo de lo que la
sociedad nos pide en ese momento
por eso yo creo que en vez de quejarse
por cosas que en cierto modo tú también
hacías deberíamos rescatar lo mejor de
las generaciones como de mis papás yo
aprendí lo que es paciencia que no todo
siempre me va a llegar de inmediato y
como yo quiero de mis abuelitos lo que
es el respeto que no puedo tratar a los
demás como se me pegue la regalada gana'
quizás ellos también podrían ver lo que
nosotros también tenemos de bueno como
tener una mente más abierta ser más
relajados que creen las cosas de
inmediato también significa ser
eficientes
pero a mí me encanta ver como grababan
un casete lo que era revelar una foto
escuchar su música o probar los delicia
de los deliciosos postres que nuestros
abuelitos les preparaban a nuestros
papás quizás pero también me encantaría
que yo que se baila al reggaeton con mi
abuelita o poder hacer referencias de
memes con mis papás o incluso bailar
esos tontos bailes ton que salen ahorita
por eso yo creo que tenemos una
oportunidad piénsenlo tal vez les
termine gustando